hey guys it's max we just got the new
Samsung Galaxy buds plus in and today
we're going to compare them to the
second-generation earpods along with the
super popular ear pods Pro that I've
been using ever since they came out I
love these things
and what I'm most excited about is to
see how these do as far as sound quality
in microphone quality that's two areas
that the original ones really lacked in
so I'm going to set this down over here
let's compare the cases the first thing
I want to mention is the new galaxy buds
plus are now shipping with a glossy
black case which does look nice where we
have glossy white for the air pod pro
cases and as far as the size it is quite
a bit bigger than the original ear pods
case it's actually thicker as well and
compared to the air pods pro case it is
still a little bit thicker a little bit
longer but size wise it's still
comfortable to fit into your pants
pocket I really like that the galaxy
buds charged with USB type-c compared to
using lightning on apples and of course
we do have wireless charging built into
the Galaxy buds plus just like the
originals and same with both of these
now Apple makes it incredibly easy to
pair your ear pods with your iPhone but
Samsung has done a very similar thing
let's pop the case open and wait for the
little icon to come up maybe it's not as
easy as on the iPhone so let me go to
the right app here oh there it is as
soon as I got my app drawer open it
noticed it let's hit connect and we are
all done all paired and everything is
running great it's actually a little bit
quicker than the original galaxy buds
I'm gonna pull one of these out and we
can start talking about comfort now I'm
a big fan of the original Galaxy buds
they are fairly comfortable they fit
into my ear as well but if you take a
look at the actual driver it is quite
large it's not huge like some others but
if we compare it to the earpiece on the
original ear pods you can see that it is
much bigger
adding the air pod pros to the mix here
you can see that it is bigger than the
original ear pods but still not as large
as the Galaxy buds but once again we do
have that stem with these whereas the
galaxy buzz sit almost flush in your ear
the Galaxy buds plus you silicon ear to
just like the air pod pros but they also
come with these wingtips that will give
you a tighter fit in your ear whereas
the original ear pods are all plastic
and it's more of a universal fit now as
far as long-term comfort if you're
listening for a long period of time I
find the original ear pods to be very
very comfortable followed by the ear pod
pros and these don't have a little stem
that stick out all of this is silicon
whereas the Galaxy buds just like most
in ear ear buds they have this little
plastic piece that goes into your ear
and it just makes it a little bit less
comfortable after a few hours and along
with that you also get some pressure
from these wingtips which you don't get
with the air pipe rows another reason
why the air pod pros are so comfortable
is the fact that they have this unique
venting feature so as soon as you put it
into your ear you will actually feel
your ear can all get plugged up just
like you would with most of these these
in-ear earbuds but then after about two
seconds you feel that pressure going
away as its equalizing it and that
really adds to long-term comfort so for
me personally using the previous Galaxy
buds and all these ear pods I would say
that with the Galaxy buds I can use them
for about one to two hours before my
ears get tired the air pod pros maybe
about three to four whereas the original
ear pods I can use them as long as a
battery life lasts without my ears
getting tired now about that battery
life this is where the new Galaxy buds
plus are very impressive the buds
themselves are rated for 11 hours of
music playback that is almost double of
what the previous ones were compared to
four and a half hours with the air pods
probe with the noise cancellation turned
on and five hours with the original ear
pods now once we factor in the cases the
galaxy buds will give you a total of 22
hours compared to over 24 hours with the
ear pods now that noise cancellation is
one of the biggest features of the air
pods Pro you can pop them into your ear
the microphones will listen to the sound
that you have in the room and it will
actually cancel it out which is really
great for loud environments especially
for airplanes stuff like that now
unfortunately the galaxy buds plus do
not have active noise cancellation
that's one of the biggest
disappointments that from people that
were waiting for these but because they
are in ears and they seal off they still
do give you a little bit of that noise
blocking or sound blocking so it's not
at the same level as the air pots but it
is there whereas if you're wearing the
original air pots not the pros this
doesn't seal off anything so putting
them into my ear I hear all of our
central air conditioning noise or
anything else that is going on around
you unless you do actually want to hear
what is going on around you that's where
the original ear pods work really well
whereas these will see a lot of your
ears but both these have the software
feature that will feed in outside sounds
into your ear so you know what's going
on let's go ahead and compare how those
work wow that noise cancellation works
excellent so I'm gonna press and hold to
go to our transparency mode Wow okay I
know this works really well too in our
original review I was shocked by how
true-life this sounds compared to most
of these so ear pods Pro excellent job
okay popped him out it sounds almost
like it does with those in let's put
these ones in the team talked a little
bit sounds like there's water running
our essential AC sounds like waters
earning okay let me turn this up now it
sounds like a loud computer fan can talk
a bit oh you sound Timmy
you sound very tinny as you guys see I
have the app open here where you can
turn on the ambient sound which isn't
enabled for a tap by default which is
probably a good thing but you can adjust
that you kind of equalize or other
settings and this app is available for
iOS as well they just released that
about a week ago
where's what the air pods you can
connect them to your Android phone but
you won't have all those customizations
and options available you can't still
switch through your settings and stuff
like that but you won't have the amount
of flexibility now one difference
between all of these is the controls
what the original air pods
what you do is you actually just tap on
them and they don't have a touch surface
but there's a little sensor inside of
there now that does work but it doesn't
work great sometimes it doesn't register
it where you don't know if it registers
it whereas with the air pod pros now we
actually just press down on the stem
you get this a little click telling you
that yes your your different commands
did get registered
now with the Galaxy buds and the buds
plus there's actually a little touch
surface here now this is more responsive
than the original earpods it's more
reliable but the downside is you can
accidentally press them much easier so
we were shooting earlier it touches my
hand it actually enables it so it's kind
of not great but better than originals
but I think my favorite are the controls
with the airpipe rose
now before we compare the microphone
quality which is supposed to be one area
where the galaxy buds plus really
improved over the last generation let's
listen to the sound quality I'm going to
start out with the original ear paws
those sound better than I expected
ok lots of bass surprisingly and quite
loud just like I remember so let's
switch over to the galaxy buds plus and
these now have dual drivers whereas the
other ones don't
okay well that was pretty good there's
definitely some differences I noticed
the high frequencies aren't as bright
there's more bass and it seems it gets
more deeper bass instead of like a boomy
bass sound quality sounds really good
you may have seen me mess with that
equalizer there and I just wanted to add
a little bit more to the highs which I
really enjoy and switching it over to
the treble boost actually helped out
quite a bit but I'm set it back to
normal here sounded as far as sound
quality these definitely sound better
than the original ear pods but now is
the big question how do they compare to
the pros okay guys well I just went back
and forth many times I mess with EQ as
well and I'll give you guys my honest
opinion and that is that the galaxy buds
Plus do sound better than the air pod
pros not a huge difference and I'm
shocked by how close this is but I think
that having those dual drivers really
helps now out of the box there is one
big difference and that's the fact that
the air pod pros do get quite a bit
louder than the Galaxy fuzz this is one
of my biggest complaints with the
original ones but going through the EQ
one thing that I noticed that I played
with all of these settings is the
dynamic mode will actually just slightly
reduce the bass ever so slightly but
give you more volume and it gets closer
to air pot pros but not all the way
there now the Galaxy buds definitely
take the win as far as bass it sounds
very nice
there's a lot of bass there in fact the
normal mode actually has too much bass
but the D anima dynamic mode makes it
sound excellent of course with the air
pods you don't have an equaliser for
them but in your apps you can switch it
so I did just to make a fair I tuned it
a little bit here in a Spotify and with
those settings both of these sound very
good so out of the box I would hand it
to the airport pros but if you're gonna
switch that setting Lisa me personally
that's where the galaxy buds plus take
the win so I have to say that I am very
impressed with the galaxy buds as far as
sound quality they also have a couple
other features if you tap on the galaxy
but if you have this in the settings it
can actually launch Spotify even if it's
clothes which may be convenient for you
and these can actually connect to two
different computers at the same time and
give you audio from both which could be
very helpful in certain situations now
lastly let's take a look and compare the
microphone quality so here are some
sample clips from all three of them this
is a microphone quality during a call
with the galaxy buds plus this is the
microphone quality during a call with
the air pods - this is the microphone
quality during a call with the air Potts
Pro so go ahead and let us know down in
the comments section below
which one had the best microphone and
how close to the Samsung get because
last time around it got smoked now it's
important to note that we didn't use
voice memos or anything like that we
actually did a phone call and we
recorded it externally into a high
quality recorder that way you guys
actually will hear the sound quality
during a call not when it's recording to
your phone which is usually worse
quality now let's go ahead and finish
off with price the new Galaxy buds plus
cost one hundred and forty nine dollars
whereas the air pods - if you don't get
the wireless charging case you can pick
them up right now for 129
brand new on Amazon we will have links
down below and with the case wireless
charging case for a 170 just a little
bit more and of course the air pods Pro
these are two hundred and fifty dollars
so that's $100 price difference between
these now which one should you buy that
is a very hard question to answer it
really depends on what you're interested
in if you're somebody that wants the
maximum comfort for listening for a very
long time I would say the air pods they
lose out in a lot of different ways -
both of these other ones but that's one
area where they still stick out and for
most people these are very comfortable
if you care mostly about sound quality
you want to listen for a long period of
time the galaxy buds sound fantastic
they have 11 hours of battery life built
into the buzz themselves so if you don't
want if you don't want to like charge
them between your listening sessions say
you work outside you want to keep it in
all day these really are great for that
other than comfort so you might have to
sacrifice with a little bit of ear
soreness now if you want a really good
audio quality and you want noise
cancellation that's where the air pod
pros come in
they sound very good not as good as the
galaxy buds but very close and you get
those extra features and as far as
comfort I can wear these for about twice
as long compared to the Galaxy buds
without my ears getting tired so let us
know which ones you would choose or
which ones you actually bought down in
the comment section below once again we
have links to all of these and if you
want to see our comparison between the
galaxy buds plus compared to the
original galaxy buzz make sure you guys
are subscribed by clicking in that
circle above in enabling notifications
and if you want to see a couple other
great videos we have them right over
there there's Ben Max and I will see you
in the next video
[Music]